[Musique]
voici de bons aliments pourtant parfois
on doit les éliminer de notre
alimentation poursuivre la diète faible
en format bd c'est pas vraiment de
maigrir du tout en arrière et l'idée
c'est d'arriver à résoudre les problèmes
digestifs des gens qui sont atteintes de
l'intestin irritable sauvages parce
qu'ils certaines personnes qui pensent
que c'est un jet à vie mais c'est
vraiment paul que le syndrome de
l'intestin irritable et le trouble
gastro-intestinal le plus répandu au
monde
au canada près à 20% de la population en
est atteint on a tous un jour ressenti
un inconfort en mangeant par exemple des
légumineuses là sachez monsieur madame
tout le monde ça peut créer quelques gaz
des ballonnements pour digérer mettons
les légumineuses
sauf que la personne qui attendent de
l'intestin irritable elle est là une
hypersensibilité en fait face à ces
réactions là il peut y avoir des
symptômes différents
ça peut être des gaz des ballonnements
des chromes de la diarrhée et de la
constipation
ce sont les sucres contenus dans
plusieurs aliments qui sont responsables
de ces problèmes
ces sucres complexes sont difficiles à
digérer et fermente dans l'intestin faut
demain en fait c'est un acronyme en
anglais qui englobe en fait les sucres
qui vont être fermentés par les
bactéries de notre colo et qui peut
causer tous les symptômes que les gens
souffrent l'intestin irritable peuvent
avoir le f ça va être pour
fermentescibles et ensuite ça va être
pour définir les sucres fait qu'on a les
oligosaccharides donc des plus grandes
chaînes de sucre pour expliquer un peu
ça va être tout les sûr que vous allez
trouver dans les légumineuses dans
certaines céréales comme le blé le
seigle l'orge mais également dans l'ail
dans l'oignon vie dans certains fruits
et légumes comme le melon d'eau par
exemple des dix hakkar est donc là on
parle du lactose que l'on va trouver
dans les produits laitiers et mc mono
saccharides donc là c'est plus pour
définir le fructose que l'on va avoir un
éclat je veux parler par exemple du miel
ou alors de la mangue assez pour end
parce que c'est en anglais et le p pour
les polyols donc tout ce qui est sucre
alcool que l'on a dans certains fruits
et légumes fait la gêne on serait le
champignon par exemple mais également
dans tout ce qui avait de produits plus
diète et boissons gazeuses diètes quand
on fait une diète fraude map
on doit éliminer ceux ici là sur la
table oui mais pas tous ceux qui sont là
il ya des choses qui en contiennent pas
oui exactement par exemple j'avais
vraiment le riz blanc qui lui n'a pas de
fondement puis les fraises qui sont
considérés comme un fruit qui ne
contient pas de faute match donc on peut
les manger sans soucis qu'elle suggère
l'avocat
je peux vérifier sur mon application
manager est difficile de savoir quel
sucre est contenue dans quel aliment est
difficile aussi de savoir à quel sucre
le corps réagit 80 g d'avocats quand
c'est rouge ça veut dire que ça contient
beaucoup de ce format plat donc ils
contiennent beaucoup de serbie tonnes
alors que vous avez vérifié une
application oui c'est ça c'est qu'en
fait tu te régales application monash
qui répertorie quel aliment contient
qu'un succès klajman vérifier pour
l'avocat et dans l'avocat le sucre qui
est contenu c'est le sorbitol la diète a
été mise au point par des chercheurs de
l'université monash en australie depuis
plusieurs études ont démontré
l'efficacité de la diète la dette faute
map se découpe en trois phases et que la
première on va aller éliminée pendant 2
à 6 semaines toutes les familles de
sucre et bien sûr après on va à les
réintégrer une famille à la fois pour
aller mettre le doigt sur celle qui nous
pose problème
donc la phase numéro trois c'est de
maintenir une diète sans ces familles là
mais uniquement celles qui nous causent
souci oui bonjour c'est sandrine du
projet de recherche phonak du centre de
recherche du chum
ça va bien c'est dans sa cour arrière en
mode télétravail que sandrine discute
avec des patients pour une étude
clinique du chum
c'est un projet pilote de recherche pas
demain dans le cas de la diète fiona ce
qu'on a remarqué c'est que beaucoup
d'études sur la diète en tant que tel
qu'on voit que ça fonctionne chez 75%
déjà environ on voit une amélioration
des symptômes itou mais il ya peu
d'études sur comment en un plan se dire
que dans la vraie vie
qu'est ce qu'on vise avec ce projet de
recherche luxe et d'évaluer dans le fond
l'impact d'un service en ligne de menus
personnalisés soit la plateforme sos
cuisine donc on veut évaluer l'impact de
toute cette plateforme le sur la qualité
de vie et les symptômes physiques et
psychologiques des gens qui ont le
syndrome de l'intestin irritable nous on
recrute par l'entremise des
gastro-entérologues donc dans la
littérature scientifique on n'a pas de
données sur d'autres moyens de donner
cette diatribe puis on sait que c'est
une dit qu'il peut être compliqué à
certains moments une diète complexe en
effet et pour faciliter la vie on trouve
aussi en épicerie de plus en plus de
produits qui affichent fraude maps sur
les emballages
et si c'est la sauce barbecue puis lé
s'en aille sans oignon son miel fixe en
toute fin de match finalement qu'on
pourrait trouver dans les aliments
classiques du commerce
c'est sûr que ça peut être tout à fait
attrayantes en mai un nouveau produit
qu'est ce que c'est comme beaucoup de
gens pensent c'est sans gluten c'est
meilleur pour la santé
barça n'a aucun lien mais c'est cent
fois demain parce que ce serait meilleur
pour la santé
et est ce que ce serait meilleur pour la
santé non non parce que tout ce qui va
être ayew nyon légumineuses
définitivement c'est un plus pour nos
tops
je voudrais que tout ce qui est un peu
dans l'alimentation peut être sujet à
l'effet de mode mais le feu ne ment pas
vraiment été mis en place pour les gens
qui souffrent de l'intestin irritable et
puis la suivre si on n'a pas ces
symptômes là ça n'a aucun aucun intérêt